thank you very much
hi my name is Felicia and today I'll be
talking to you about equip Aryans don't
worry if you haven't heard the term
before you're not really familiar with
it I'll talk you through it but what I
want to do in this talk is show you how
we use a simple observation of how
convolutional neural networks work and
why they're so applicable to image
analysis and how we manage to use that
and build a new type of convolutional
neural convolutional layer that is more
data efficient and more effective for
the problems we're working with at the
end is this led to this new kind of
convolutional layer that we call the
group conclusion and we applied it to a
medical problem the problem of long
module detection and the end result was
that we actually only need one tenth of
the data that we needed in the original
problem and yeah I'll show you how
that's done but before we go to that
I'll talk a little bit about conflation
all neural networks so this is my dog in
there and it's a picture of dog and if
you have enough training data and you
train a neural network to recognize this
it's pretty easy to recognize that this
is a dog and this is another picture of
the same dog and for us it's quite easy
to recognize that is again another dog
and for an conflation of neural network
that is also quite easy to recognize if
you have enough label training data to
detect the dog in the first place it
doesn't really particularly matter where
the dog is in the image it will still be
able to pick it up and give the same
prediction the same label to it we call
this invariance invariance to
translation specifically and it's one of
the reasons why convolutional neural
networks are so particularly suited for
image analysis because in images this
happens a lot
that's something is in one point in the
image or in different location and it's
quite nice that it's able to pick that
up and you don't need to augment the
data set or anything like that and CNN's
confliction of neural networks our
invariance of translation is what we say
however if you rotate an image if you
have a CNN that recognizes if
have a model that recognizes talks and
you happen to rotate an image and that
that rotated version of the image was
not in the original trading data set
it's completely incomprehensible like
this rotary picture of a dog is suddenly
not a dog anymore and there are other
types of transformations
besides rotation such as reflection or
scaling and many types of others that
cns are not invariant to and the way we
deal with this right now is normally
data augmentation we have one image in
the training dataset so like the upper
image and we create various forms of
that image transform form to state image
reflected rotated we add noise we scale
it and we add these to the training data
set and we basically train on these as
well we say these are examples of dogs
as well but what's interesting is we
don't need to do this for translation
which is also a type of transformation
so why do we need to do this for trends
for rotation and reflection but we don't
need to do this for translation the
reason for this is specifically the way
that the conclusion operator works so in
a fully connected Nets each node in a
layer is connected to each next each
node in the next layer and you basically
have a lot of ways because each
connection has its own weight in a
convolution no layer however each it has
associated filters which are small set
of weights that are involved over the
inputs to produce output feature Maps
the same filter sort of the same set of
weights is used all over the image to
produce various outputs and the value
over weight is therefore not sides with
single inputs but to multiple inputs so
we say that the ways are shared because
we use the same set of weights in
multiple location a shift in the input
image basically results in that the
features still picked up but at a
different points it results in a similar
shift in the feature Maps basically we
call this equivalence so equal variances
translation specifically this is not the
same as in variance because equivalence
means that if it
Automation is applied to but a similar
transformation is also applied to the
outputs and invariance means that a
transformation that is applied to the
inputs does not really influence the
output result it still produces the same
outlet to the same label but the reason
why equal variance in the convolutional
layer leads to invariance in the
convolutional neural network is because
inside a convolutional neural network
you have convolution layers but you also
typically have some form of
dimensionality reduction and the
dimensionality reduction basically
reduces the spatial information and by
reducing a spatial information the
features still picked up in some way and
then the information is reduced and then
we still get the same label at the ends
so to summarize the equal variant
property of the convolutional layer
itself
combined with the dimensionality
reduction of the of the network leads to
translation invariance which means that
a shift in inputs is simply disregarded
and image still produces the same output
[Music]
so this led us to the question what if
we could extend this this weight sharing
property that leads to variance to also
be equal variance or other types of
transformations could we could we
generalize the way sharing property at
least equal variance or other types of
transformations other than the
translation obviously I wouldn't be
standing here telling you all this if
the answer is no that would be quite
anticlimactic so this is basically what
we're focusing on we're focusing on
building in equal variance not only to
translation but also to rotations and
reflections and for this particular
project we're focusing on lossless
transformations so it means for example
90-degree rotations or lossless while if
you do a 10 degree rotation you because
you have to distort the image in some
way it is not completely lossless and in
particular we're focusing on groups of
transformations that together are
basically closed so an example of a
group is the group of 90 degree
rotations if you apply 90 degree
rotations consecutively you get back to
the original image and you can
basically combined 90-degree rotations
to from other all other rotations in the
group like a 180 degree rotation is
basically just two 90-degree rotations
this group of transformations of
90-degree rotations has four elements we
say because that's a closed group you
can see the image here you see how these
combines to form the same image again we
can also have some beer groups for
example if you add reflection or the
mirroring operation you get a group with
eight elements and if you do this in 3d
I can tell you it gets a little bit more
complicated even if we want to build in
equivalence to a group of
transformations that are basically two
approaches you can take one is to create
rotated versions of the output feature
Maps so the output of the convolution
and the other is to create edited
versions of basically what we use to
produce output the filters honestly
rotate and feature maps is a little bit
easier to implement but it's also more
costly so that's why we're focusing on
the latter but both approaches are
basically very usable and produce the
same results so the question is now how
do we use this and how do we build an
equivalence this is quite a mathematical
heavy story and I'm trying to keep the
mass down to a absolute minimum on these
slides but the very very simple
explanation of this is that we first
create an augment it's filter Bank by
transforming each filter by each
transformation in the chosen group so
the group is for example the four
90-degree rotations then we have these
dis augment and filter Bank that's a
little bit bigger than the original
filter Bank like four times as big for
example and we apply a regular
convolution with the Augmented filter
Bank instead of the original filters so
in other words starting with a filter
with learning normal parameters we
produce a number of transferred copies
of this learn about filter which is not
learned but we use the same ways again
we just create a rotated version or a
transform version
and we use we convolve those to convolve
and create output feature Maps yeah
the effect of this is that obviously we
get more output filter Maps but some of
these belong together basically so if
you have one normal filter and it has it
reduces for orientation channels for the
90 degree rotations which itch
pick up the same feature but in a
different orientation
we call these orientation channels
because the various orientations of the
same feature and the number of
orientation channels we produce are
dependent on the size of the group so
for 90 degree rotations it would be 4 or
a 90-degree rotations with reflections
it would be 8 you can get a lot of
groups and this leads to equal variance
the reason that this equivalence is that
if you transform the inputs like the
input image that you put in it still
picks up the same features but and it's
still the orientation channels remain
the same so you still have the same
orientation channels for this feature it
is just that these orientation channels
are now shuffled basically so there is
some kind of transformation applied to
the orientation to the output but it is
still picked up and we still have the
same information at the end this is how
equal variance is preserved throughout
that is suggested that I would love to
go into more detail about this but it
would be very mass heavy for a talk like
this I mean if you want to know more
about this please come find me I love
this about the subject but I also
recommend you read these papers the
first one by Taco Cohan and Mark
swelling introduced the concept of group
equatorial neural networks and prove
their effectiveness in terms of that
efficiency and rotated em nice and C for
10 then we talked for me use this and
extended it to the 3d version so it was
also usable for 3d convolutions which
made it clickable to medical data and we
proved that it was actually way more
efficient even in the 3d domain and if
you want to know even more maths about
this it's there's a general theory of
equivalence and CNN said I could really
recommend there's also
a lot of other type of research done on
the subjects yeah have a look at these
papers but for now I want to be focusing
on specifically did 3d caves are the
reason is that I am working on this and
I'm actually using this in practice to
implement the 3d case it was a little
bit more complicated than a 2d case
because rotations and reflections in 3d
are a lot more complicated than they are
in 2d like at the top here you see the
2d rotations it's just four elements in
this of the square but if you want to if
you take all the lossless
transformations of a cube you already
have 24 different elements and if you
have reflection if you add that to it
you get 48 elements it gets quite
complicated and yeah so but the reason
why we were doing this because is
because on the 2d case it already proved
that using the group equatorial neural
networks was data efficient and in 3d
the using data augmentation is already a
bit more complicated because you have so
many options and also in the medical
domain where I work basically a large
say large spaces are pretty hard to come
by any labeled annotations from experts
from doctors and honestly that's just
you often run into the problem that you
don't have enough data so we were really
interested to see if we could use this
to apply to medical image data the
problem
we specifically tackled was that of
pulmonary nodule detection pulmonary
nodules or lung nodules as we call them
our suspect lesions in the lung visible
on a CT scan they may be malignant they
may not be able ignant but there are
basically early signs of lung cancer so
they're pretty relevant to detect but
also pretty hard to detect on the top
here you see a single slice of a CT scan
of the chest and the thing that's I
don't know if you can see it on the
slide but the thing in the top that is
one of the things we need to detect but
it's a black-and-white image it's quite
difficult to find and typically we have
about 300 of these images to format a
full 3d volume if you
techno chills because you have 300
images that are basically 500 by 500
pixels it's quite difficult to just
throw it into a scene and in one go so
we first do Canada generation we analyze
the whole volume for suspect lesions
anything that might be a little bit odd
and then we do a corner of a
classification of non-inertial versus
nodule on all the candidates that
reduces the amount false positives that
we have and also one of the reasons why
we chose this particular application
besides that it's of course very
relevant to the technolon cancer and in
early stage is also because we have a
large training data set available which
is pretty rare in the medical domain
this large training data set comes from
the National lung screening trial in the
US and we also have a high quality test
set available from the latc
and this test set is basically annotated
by four different expert radiologists so
we're pretty sure that the quality is
good
so this enabled us to test whether our
group convolutions actually were were
effective on this domain yeah so we
wanted to evaluate whether our CN NS
with their improved equal variants
actually performed better than a regular
CN n and a way to do this was first to
train a baseline CNN just a regular
normal neural network and make sure that
it's competitive with the Luna 16 Grand
Challenge - Luna 16 grand challenge is a
challenge posed by Radford University
which is basically the lung nodule
detection challenge and we train a
neural network that got a top 10
performance so it was like pretty some
pretty good and then we simply replaced
every convolution in the CNN that we
beta trained based on CNN and replace it
with one of our own accomplishments so
the group convolutions we still use the
same training validation test dataset
that didn't change we also use the same
architecture besides you know the
difference between normal evolutions
group convolutions and hyper parameters
we still use data augmentation I think
this is very important to notice
obviously there are other types of
transformations that these networks are
not invariant or equatorial against
and we still used rotation for you know
the ten degree rotations that we talked
about we use exactly the same data
augmentation scheme and we use the same
number of parameters and because our
interest specifically lie in finding out
if this is actually more data efficient
or not which means we use less more or
less training this training data we
train this on four different training
set data set sizes so obviously the the
baseline was trained on the largest
training data set side we use the same
baseline and we use the group
accomplishes for 30 samples 300 samples
3,000 samples and 30,000 samples and we
were interested in to see if we saw
pattern in the results we did so these
are the results of our over baseline
versus the results of our group
convolutional neural network the scores
are calculated by having a sort of a
trade-off between sensitivity and false
positive rate it's the same way as the
Lunik ranch and calculates our overall
system score and we notice that for the
biggest available dataset size of 30,000
samples are CNN or so the G CNN already
performs a little bit better than the
baseline which is which is pretty nice
because in this region like the scores
are all pretty close and it got us from
a top ten performers to a top three
performance I think but what I thought
was way more interesting is that the
smaller the data set the training
dataset gets so to 3330 the more
pronounced difference between the
performance of the G CNN versus the
baseline gets and if you take a close
look at this particular bar chart you
notice that for every G CNN that is
trained it performs better or roughly
equal to a normal baseline seen and
trained on ten times as much data so for
example I think that's clears under 30
versus 300 example but it goes for every
every result of we go so for our
particular application the TCM was
roughly as good as the baseline trend
and ten times among the amount of data
for someone like me who works in
the medical domain were a large datasets
are scarce that efficiency is absolutely
essential and by observing while CNN's
are so efficient and useful for image
analysis in the first place we've
managed to extend this in a way that
reduce the data requirements by tenfold
and I can also tell you we already do a
couple of other related problems and we
saw the same trends and something I
didn't mention in the slides but it's
also very interesting to mention is that
specifically for long lines for
detection like I said not all lung
nodules are malignant but we showed an
extreme extreme more sensitivity to
malignant modules versus benign nodules
which is also very interesting because
that is something we didn't even train
on yeah so jason has as far as we've
seen are way more data efficient in both
2d and 3d and group conclusions are
extremely easy to use we have a package
that's available it's available in four
Kiara's tensorflow pi torch and even
chain if that's your preferred framework
which I don't know and you can just use
the group conclusions as a drop as a
drop-in replacement for your normal
convolutions and keep everything else
the same and for us that has proved very
beneficial so I am really looking
forward to seeing other people use it as
well i if you have any questions if you
want to try this out if you have any
other ideas please contact me and thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
Thank You Maria for your talk now we
have some time for any questions anybody
have any questions
hello hello do we know why the human
brain actually doesn't have any problems
with this invariance and because we can
just tilt our head and then we don't
have any recognition problems what are
we doing differently well I don't think
I'm the right person to tell you this
I'm not on your scientists I'm just the
data scientist but yeah I don't know
it's just that for us it's obviously it
becomes sort of it I you also see it
with the rotated image of the dog it's a
little bit more difficult but for us
it's still quite easy to see and I don't
know why but that's true we can do it
though hi thanks for the excellent talk
and thanks for your project I'm
wondering how this would relate to data
augmentation if you would simply do the
same operations augmented wouldn't it be
the same efficiency data wise but just
slower to train in the end yeah that's
actually a good question one of the
experiments that we did was perform all
the augmentations that we try to be
equivalent towards at test time so
basically averaging predictions over
various see how the you have to test
image you perform all the organ that he
create all the various predictions based
on the all the transformations applied
to it an average that did lead to an
increase in score compared to normal
baseline results but still or dissonance
were a lot better than using that so
maybe this question would actually be
better with if you had an image but did
you examine the kinds of filters that
these group convolution
layers actually produce one train no
there is actually something I got asked
before and that was something that we
wanted to do but there's there's so much
research still have to do in this
subject there's also some follow-up
research is being done right now as we
haven't really had the time to it but it
is something that's interesting and we
wanted to take a look at it just didn't
get around to yet
any other questions right now thank you
too for the great talk how does it
relate to capsule nets I think they
wanted to achieve the Train yeah yeah I
don't know much about capsule nets
I do know that there is actually one of
the same idea is that they have that you
build in some priors basically
beforehand we haven't compared them if
that's your question but it would be I
think the same reason why capsule
modular or sometimes a good choice is
the same for this because they do the
same thing and maybe one quick follow-up
did you'll also see some improvement in
training times sorry that you will see
reduced training times that is also an
interesting question because it is
because we do recreate rotated versions
of the filter and we have to come up
with this is actually least do it an
increase in training time but one of the
things we notice is that GCN's have a
chance to converge much faster so while
each epoch takes a little bit longer to
train you need to train way lines for a
smaller amount of time another question
hi I was wondering um have you also
explored other other kinds of
transformations so for example scaling I
could imagine the same and can they be
complied combined into one group
convolution there there is a that is
also a very interesting question
not me personally but I do know that
there is a lot of research being done
and to equip Aryans and any parents
especially equivalence right now and
scaling is one of the interesting
research areas so there are others that
have attempted this and do a kind of a
similar thing to achieve equal variances
scaling
I have a question the data sets as you
mentioned are those open and accessible
to people not at our University
oh yeah so I used two data sets the
first is the National lung screening
trial and the second is to LA DC it's
really database the second one a test
set is available on the Grand Challenge
website that I mentioned it's just it's
an open Grand Challenge you can just
download the data immediately and the C
is a semi semi public you can get the
data but you have to submit a proposal
about what you want to do with the data
and then you did it and one more for
people that are interested in pursuing
vision neural networks is there a
resource that you think is most
important while also being accessible
that people could look into just to get
into convolutional neural networks and
training it on vision or data like what
you I think there are a lot of resources
available and mine are a lot of courses
available online what I really want to
want to tell people is don't just do it
don't just implement a network like an
example that you see try to understand
why the different layers who work the
way they do try to understand what's
actually happening because for me
personally when I first got into image
analysis and vision I didn't actually
realize what conclusions were how they
worth why this was better for everything
Alice's I just accepted that it was
better than no further connected meant
for example try to understand why you're
doing what you're doing I think I was
the great
and if this group convolutional layers
could have an intense transformation for
the generative models like convolution
transpose upscaling so if this generic
group convolution nodes could have a
inverse transformation for up scaling
yeah in order to build some generative
models um we haven't worked with that
yet but I imagine you can extend it to
do that yes I see that there are no more
questions thank you very much for your
talk
[Applause]